bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
petit rendez vous du mercredi
loki épisode 3 vient de sortir un
épisode un petit peu particulier par
rapport aux deux premiers et j'avoue
être assez intrigué alors essayons de
déceler quelques détails dans ce
brouillard de mystère bien évidemment si
ce petit rendez vous vous plaît
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner pour ne
louper aucune des prochaines vidéos sur
l'eau qui vous êtes nombreux à regarder
les vidéos sans être abonné c'est le
moment de le faire
bon tout d'abord il faut qu'on reparle
de la pseudo lady loki qui s'appelle au
final sylvie vous étiez très nombreux à
m'avoir partager l'information que cette
lady l'eau qui s'appelait sylvie avant
même l'épisode 3 à cause des crédits et
c'était bien jouer de votre part car
cela remettait tout en cause par rapport
à son identité puisque pour beaucoup il
s'agirait de sylvie lâche tonnes une
jeune fille dont les pouvoirs ont été
données par loki dans les comics et qui
feront d'elle à l'avenir l'enchanteresse
et du coup j'attends d'en savoir plus
notamment l'épisode 3 pour mieux
appréhender cette idée déjà dans les
détails maintenant que nous connaissons
mieux sylvie l'identité de
l'enchanteresse colle bien au personnage
effectivement elle est blonde comme
l'enchanteresse elle a sa petite
couronne comme l'eau qui est surtout
elle possède un pouvoir d'illusions ou
plutôt de manipulation mentale
c'est un petit peu son pouvoir signature
sans oublier qu'elle a appris à
contrôler ses pouvoirs
seul exactement comme dans les comics
mais il ya d'autres détails encore plus
intrigant premièrement il ne faut pas
oublier que nous sommes dans le mc et
donc que nous sommes face à une
réécriture est une réinterprétation des
histoires des comics et donc plus
particulièrement du personnage en
lui-même
donc nous devons rester sur nos gardes
et c'est ça qui est perturbant car
l'enchanteresse n'est normalement pas
l'eau qui met un personnage qui est lié
à ce dernier
alors que dans la série on veut nous
faire comprendre qu'elle est une
variation de l'eau qui nous pouvons
prendre l'exemple du message qu'instaure
la série un message important sur
l'identité sylvie ne se sent pas l'eau
qui elle
même pas être assimilé à ça c'est
pourquoi elle et sylvie si elle est
véritablement un personnage qui n'a rien
à voir avec l'eau qui à la base cela
fout en l'air complètement le message du
coup puis nous retrouvons des éléments
de caractère propre à ce dernier comme
le cri de colère que l'on retrouve dans
thor 2 dark world ou bien tout
simplement le glorieux destin
qu'aujourd'hui même lot qui trouve
ridicule un trait de caractère qui le
symbolisent est énormément dans le mc eu
avec des plans qui foirent toujours même
mobius se moquer de lui par rapport à ça
dans le premier épisode
je suis donc d'avis que sylvie enee
l'eau qui comme les autres variations de
ce dernier qui ont été stoppées
chacun possède son propre physique sa
propre histoire mais néanmoins que
l'enchanteresse va naître par rapport à
ce changement d'identité est dans le
fonctionnement c'est un petit peu comme
agatha harkness qui était la voisine
toute gentille et qui s'est révélé être
la sorcière méchante dans one la vision
nous étions face à un personnage
emblématique des comics mais dévoilée
sous une autre forme pour le mc eu c'est
du moins ma perception en tout cas
d'ailleurs nous sommes très loin de tout
savoir concernant sylvie pour le moment
puisque nous savons que keighley fleming
fait partie du casting et elle est
censée jouer une version plus jeune de
sylvie proposer des scènes avec une
version plus jeune d'un personnage comme
pourquoi pas des flashbacks c'est pour
étoffer l'histoire est racontée les
origines de ce dernier donc il faut nous
attendre tout de même à des révélations
sur sylvie peut-être que finalement elle
est la création de l'eau qui vient comme
dans les comics bref nous sommes à
l'abri de rien en tout cas pour
continuer nous devons parler de ses
souvenirs et de la métaphore de la scène
de début de l'épisode ce genre de scènes
proposées intelligemment par la série
certes à vulgariser les concepts qu'elle
propose comme pour comment fonctionne le
temps où le phénomène d apocalypse où tu
peux
mettre le bazar comme tu veux toute
façon tout va disparaître et bien ici
la scène nous démontre qu'à cause du
froid les synapses gel et donc des
souvenirs se frise d'un coup et c'est un
comble puisque sylvie nous affirme
qu'elle ne se souvient pas vraiment de
son passé elle ne se rappelle en aucun
cas de sa mère c'est aujourd'hui juste
un vague rêve et vu qu'elle pose la
question justement à l'agent de la tva
qu'elle a kidnappé on peut se demander
si c'est justement lié à la tva et c'est
même sûr alors at elle déjà eu affaire à
la tva c'est vraiment ça qui me pose
question car le phénomène qu'elle
explique et dont elle semble
possiblement faire l'objet est liée à
ces derniers sauf qu'elle est inconnue
pour la tva
ils ne savent pas qui elle est
réellement il utilise rime donc lui pour
la désigner en pensant que c'est un lot
qui est pourtant ils savent que c'est
invariant de l'eau qui sans oublier qu
aucune magie ne fonctionne à la tva donc
elle n'a pas pu cacher sa véritable
identité
il y a un lien très étrange entre elle
et ces derniers et pour parler plus
précisément de la tva il est temps de
traiter les normes bombe qui a été lâché
dans l'épisode
apparemment les agents et les membres de
la tva serait des personnes normales et
donc bas des variants cela rejoint
complètement ce qu'on disait dans la
vidéo précédente sur kang et cetera la
tva fait de la propagande avec la vidéo
de miss minutes
il y as complètement une double lecture
puisqu'il est dit que les time keeper
ont créé les agents de la tva alors oui
ils sont créés mais sur des gens déjà
existants et ne sont pas originaires de
la tva du coup donc cela sous-entend que
beaucoup de gens de la tva sont
prisonniers de leur sort en quelque
sorte surtout si leurs souvenirs ont été
effacés sylvie a d'ailleurs raviver un
souvenir de plusieurs siècles à l'agent
qu'elles avaient kidnappés
une agent dont l'esprit est embrouillée
comme si elle avait été formatée pour la
tva en reniant donc tout son passé
sauf qu'au final le piège est très
vicieux car en intégrant des gens
ordinaire à la tva ils deviennent donc
des variants puisqu'ils sortent du flux
éternel temporelle pour justement
atterrir dans ce lieu hors du temps
donc cela veut dire qu'après c'est soit
la tva soit tu finis désintégrer quoi
évidemment je pense que raven arènes
slayer est au courant de tout ça puisque
elle retranscrit à la perfection les
ordres des thèmes qui peuvent vraiment
elle cache quelque chose
mais qu'en est-il de mobius pour moi
pour que la série prenne un tournant
encore plus intéressant si le but est de
faire tomber justement la dictature de
la tva ou du moins révélé les vilains
qui abusent de leur pouvoir
il faut une taupe dans l'organisation
quelqu'un qui va se rebeller et se
retourne et justement contre eux car
c'est contraire à ses valeurs
une mécanique populaire que l'on
retrouve dans plusieurs oeuvres comme
monica rambo dans rwanda vision qui
s'est retournée contre le sword pour
aider rwanda comme nebula et camorra par
rapport à la noce ou comme l'eau qui
tout simplement premier ennemi des
avengers puis au final redevenu le frère
de thor mobius est d'ailleurs fan de jet
ski et ne semble en avoir jamais fait un
concept étrange un membre d'une
entreprise suprême hors du temps et de
l'espace est fan de jet ski c'est très
anodin et ce n'est pas placé ici par
hasard
cela confirme clairement que moby lui
c'est invariant lui aussi est pire que
ça tout son côté dépressif grisâtre
mossad traduirait un sentiment lui
d'acceptation de son sort il est
condamné à travailler pour la tva à
jamais sans jamais rien espérer derrière
et au vu de son âge et de son ancienneté
il fait peut-être partie des premiers
agents de la tva
bref mobius va nous révéler de grandes
choses dans les prochains épisodes
je peux le garantir enfin voilà dans
tous les cas je garde quand même
l'optique que la série law qui installe
tranquillement l'arrivée de kango
conquérant il n'apparaitra pas
spécialement dans la série mais
plusieurs détails cherche d'amont
et son existence à devoir en tout cas
les répercussions sur le futur de marvel
vu comment tout est contrôlé ça va
forcément péter à un moment ou un autre
sinon comment voulez vous qu'on voit les
les trois pie dit tout simplement
réunies ou que wendat puisse parcourir
le multivers tranquillement bref
j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à laisser
un petit pouce bleus et à laisser un
petit commentaire avec ce que vous avez
pensé de l'épisode
il était très beau d'ailleurs
visuellement je trouve avec le petit
plan séquence à la fin qui était
vraiment bien maîtrisé puis n'hésitez
pas à vous abonner également on va
reparler de l'eau qui bien évidemment il
reste trois épisodes aller c'était argot
rock le 'lion' rares soit avec vous ciao
tout le monde
[Musique]